plenty of news today's the day that the
commissioner had his annual
press conference people call it the
state of the league address it's never
really that it's roger goodell shows up
has some sort of preliminary comment 30
seconds 45 seconds whatever it may be
and then he just opens it up to
questions they used to always do it on
friday and they backed off for friday
because by friday there's more reporters
in town than there is on wednesday this
year the happy medium of thursday
because nobody was in town yesterday so
they did it today and we're going to
talk about sharing some of the things
that he discussed let's begin with a
clip from the goodell press conference
regarding the nfl's current success or
lack thereof when it comes to increased
minority hires in key positions here's
godel
i wonder if you would consider
you know having some sort of an
ownership summit or something to
and i don't mean read the riot act to
owners but i mean to try to talk to
owners personally or maybe in in a large
group when you can get together
about emphasizing that we are not doing
this well we've got to do it better
peter everything you just said there
i've said uh on multiple occasions this
year as i said to you
in response to the question lindsay asks
i'm not sure other than the february
meeting where we discussed the labor
agreement
that we didn't raise
this issue and the importance of
doing this better considering policies
to help us in this case
and enacting policies and the
ownership's shown their commitment in
that so the answer is yes we'll have
more discussions for sure um both
individually and collectively when we
can get together but that doesn't stop
us we've been doing it on zoom we've
been doing it individually and the
committee has been very active too
chaired by art rooney and several owners
that are on that committee and
continuing to look what are the changes
we still need to make and i'll reinforce
again why we may be disappointed in the
head coaches uh at the end of the day
there are a lot of positives here that
we need to build on and we need to
continue to make progress on and that
commitment is there
tom curran inspired for me the phrase
that roger goodell is the world's
highest paid pin cushion and in many
respects shireen that is true he is the
face that deals with questions like that
issues like that so the 32 owners can
quietly hide behind the curtain while
goodell does it in a situation like this
though there's a combination of being
the pin cushion but also the cat herder
and you have to herd these billionaire
cats and it's not easy and at the end of
the day these folks are going to do
what they want to do
individually collectively it shows it's
not good enough individually good luck
convincing any of them to do anything
other than what they damn well want to
do
and here we are mike it's a new year
it's the same question it's the same
question we had last year the year
before the year before that to the nfl
they expanded the rooney rule
it got more interviews it didn't result
in more hirings we saw david colley go
to houston and we saw robert sala go to
the jets and that was it and with the
league that's 70 percent minority as far
as its players goes it's just not good
enough with where they are now
in the coaching now i do agree with him
they made strides with general managers
and they made strides with coordinators
they did not make strides with the head
coaches and art rooney talked last week
about having to expand the rule again i
don't know what else you do to expand
the rule because as you said mike each
individual owner is going to act on his
own
now i hope that the
creation of a pipeline that will be more
robust will result naturally in more
minority candidates becoming head
coaches but that's where the numbers
become glaring if you've got 70 percent
of the league
the players are black 35
i think is the number that i've seen out
there over and over again of the
assistant coaches and then a
ridiculously small percentage less than
10 percent blackhead coaches there's
something missing
in that in that progression
and one key is
the opportunity to groom the requirement
to groom the obligation to give
opportunities because there are of all
races and shapes and sizes there are
qualified candidates they just need the
chance to grow they need the chance to
blossom they need the chance to develop
and i think that's a big part of this
but look here's the other reality
and
this is the thing that
i would assume the nfl prefer i not say
this is the thing that i never hear
anyone else say in the media so it could
mean that i'm in la la land with this
but but
i believe the calculation has been made
at the highest levels of the league
specifically jeff pasch the general
counsel who advises roger goodell on
legal matters i think they are
comfortable and confident that yes
there's a pr component to this and yes
they're going to take some flack
periodically but there really isn't a
risk of anyone suing them over it that's
the thing that spurred action with the
creation of the rooney rule it was cyrus
mary and johnny cochran banging on the
door saying you guys are going to get
sued and you're going to lose 19 years
later i don't think they have that fear
i think they know there's no one out
there who's going to give up his career
or risk giving up his career because
there's a chance you become the colin
kaepernick of coaches if you're the one
who files the lawsuit against the nfl
alleging racial bias in hiring practices
i think they believe that they aren't at
risk of that and until they believe they
are at risk of that they're going to
talk every year they're going to take
the heat roger goodell is going to earn
part of his millions and millions of
dollars in compensation by being the one
who has to answer the questions they get
through it and then they just move on i
feel like that is the track it's going
to continue to stay on without any type
of dramatic change being forced because
it won't be forced without the threat of
litigation
and and we've expanded it mike and i'm
sure they'll expand it some way going
forward but unless owners are committed
to hiring a minority coach it's just not
going to happen at the same time i have
been as critical of anyone as houston
and and you have too we've been very
critical of the texans uh the past
however long months
but i will give them full credit for
this because just because no one's heard
of a head coach doesn't mean he can't be
a good head coach and we talk all the
time about minorities getting a chance
they're out there they just need to find
them houston did a great job of finding
one they think they can win with and
david calling and just because people
haven't heard about him doesn't mean
that he can't do a good job and he
hasn't done a good job in the past so
they hired a minority coach i will give
them full credit for that and i think
they had three minorities on their
finalist list for the head coaching
position so if i'm going to give houston
credit for anything it's going to be for
that but let me ask you this mike do you
think there would be less criticism if
eric the enemy had gotten say the
houston job instead of david cauley
would there have been less criticism now
of the league and it's minority hiring
i think if he'd gotten any job there
would have been less criticism because
let's face it with cully there's still
this perception and possible reality
that it was a jackie used to be inside
job that this is a guy that jackie used
to be knows won't threaten the fiefdom
that he used to be has created he's
going to be so grateful to have a job at
age 65 when it looked like his ship was
never going to come in the ship wasn't
even on the horizon for david cully so
all of a sudden he gets an opportunity
to be a head coach he ain't going to
rock the boat and to the extent that
there's any truth to the notion that's
kicking around league circles that it's
cully for a few years and then they
groom josh mccown who has not yet been
named to david cauley's staff but we'll
see if that ultimately happens that
that's part of this easter bee master
plan that's what undermines the kali
hire in the view of people who are
plugged in that kali is part of this
broader master plan that jack easterby
has concocted and he's just a pawn on
the chessboard eric the enemy would have
been a different dynamic altogether in
houston he's a guy who's going to come
in and as i've said before tell jack
eastwood get the hell out of my locker
room that's one of the reasons why i
think the enemy and others didn't get
that job because it cuts against what
easter b's trying to do so that's my
hesitation but i agree that if anyone
had hired the enemy it wouldn't be a
problem because he's the guy who's on
on deck he's there he's not in the on
deck circle he's in the batter's box and
he's in the spot that has produced doug
peterson super bowl winner matt nagy
coach of the year and eric the enemy's
been stalled there
and he's been the offensive coordinator
of the three years that patrick mahomes
was the quarterback so
again i and and then i saw that andy
reid said that the eagles
ultimately didn't interview eric the
enemy when they created the impression
that they did it's look uh this is going
to continue to hover over the league
until someone hires eric the enemy and i
just fear and this gets back to the
billionaires privilege they can say well
these are things we need to address but
you have to ultimately convince one of
the billionaires to hire eric the enemy
and i feel like at a certain level they
don't like the rest of us telling what's
telling them what to do
period yeah there's no question about
that mike and they're going to continue
to do
what they do and i'm not sure how you
expanded any further i mean they
said you have to interview more minority
candidates okay they did that and more
minorities were interviewed than ever
before that part of it worked and then
they were going to give these incentives
to teams that developed minority
uh candidates who were hired well they
they've done that now so i don't know
where you go from here how you expand
the rule because ultimately it is up to
these owners to to hire minority
candidates and they just haven't done it
year after year after year after year
and and here be enemy sits yet again
looking looking for a head coaching job
that hasn't come to him and frankly like
you said he's earned it he's the next
guy he's in the batter's box and he's
been in the batter's box now for three
years
one of the other aspects of the hiring
process that others have advocated we've
been banging that drum this hiring cycle
as well
tabling all interviews and hires until
after the super bowl roger goodell was
asked about that today here's that
exchange
this is um an issue we had a lot of
discussion with the fritz pilot alliance
who we worked very closely on developing
the policies this offseason
many coaches
and you know it's something i'm sure
will be brought back up again
as you know this off this season uh as
part of our policy where technology
really actually was a benefit for us
was this technology we're going through
right now virtual they were able to have
interviews
by zoom and that gave coaches an
opportunity to interview without being
as disruptive for their preparations
while they're in the postseason head
coaches felt better about it i've talked
to a couple other coaches that are in
the league now that didn't get an
opportunity both white and black who
talked about that potential change
and so we'll have to balance that and
think if if that's the right
outcome or whether there's some other
alternative
they've gotten a phone call from
microsoft after the gratuitous reference
to zoom that's a different business
issue altogether for the national
football league i probably shouldn't
have said that but i don't care um and
the point is yeah they're going to talk
about it you know they talk about it
they talk about everything let's talk
about this let's talk about that there's
a difference between talk and action
there's plenty of time for talking and
they talk and they talk and they talk
and they talk they're so afraid of
unintended consequences that becomes the
excuse for avoiding any meaningful
change and i hate that phrase unintended
consequences to me sharing is a cop-out
for we don't want to or we're not able
to sit down and brainstorm the
reasonably foreseeable consequences of
what we are going to do it doesn't take
a whole lot of creativity or brain power
to spot 10 15 20 things that you can
anticipate on the back end of any major
change you make and yes there would be
unintended consequences but no
unforeseen no first there would be
expected consequences that you would
weigh as part of the effort to consider
this change but i think it's a smart
change i think it's a necessary change
because what it does it eliminates that
inherent conflict of interest that the
assistant coach has regardless of race
regardless of background regardless of
anything when you're under consideration
for that job you're balancing how much
time do i put into preparation for my
interview how much time do i put into
getting ready for the next game in the
post season it's a horrible burden to
put on an assistant coach and the best
thing to do is table everything until
after the super bowl
and they're always worried mike about
falling behind in the race for assistant
coaches because if if somebody fills a
job early they're hiring the best
available assistant coaches and leaving
the rest out there for the last hire in
this case it was houston so you're
having to make hires of of other people
who are no longer available so there's
some of that so if you push everyone
back past the super bowl there's not
that
uh
urgency to go hire a head coach so you
can get the assistant coaches you want
because they'll all be there if everyone
has to wait to hire a
head coach and i think that's important
i do think that will help anything you
can do to make it better to level the
playing field to give these guys more of
a chance to become head coaches i think
is great
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports